okay today we are talking space planes
[Music]
a very weird sci-fi sort of idea
they are not quite planes they're not
quite
rockets but hopefully they will be a
cheap
and quick way to get things to space and
the company we're gonna visit that's
making one of these space planes is
called
dawn aerospace they're based in
new zealand one of the co-founders is a
guy named stefan powell
the company is pretty young they've just
built their first prototype
and so with that let's head way
to the bottom of the world in
christchurch and talk to stefan
[Music]
we're at this interesting time and
you're in an interesting place when it
comes to rocketry
there's a little bit of race going on to
make these small
rockets that are cheap and that you
could launch all the time
the rocket lab which has got its main
operations in auckland
is the clear leader so far they're the
only ones that have really launched
then you guys have almost like an even
more radical take
on getting rapid access to space so i
mean give me the like 10 000
foot view of what what don is trying to
do yeah so
um i mean dawn is a space transportation
company in
in a very general sense you know that
space launch
that's maneuvering things around in
space and eventually that means getting
stuff back down to earth as well
and okay and then in terms of like
getting stuff to space i mean you guys
have this awesome
space plane and give me like sort of the
specs
i'm like the first one that you're
building yeah so the the first plane
that we're building
the mark ii aurora is about 280
kilograms take off weight
about 2.5 meter wingspan and it flies
out of regular airports
that's the point our space plane will be
certified under aircraft law
it'll fly as an aircraft and so we will
have a licence to fly the vehicle as
opposed
to a rocket launch license for that one
flight
yeah well and so for people who like
know nothing about this i mean
before every rocket launcher is like
you've got to apply for this license
which is this whole timely and costly
process and then you've got to clear the
airspace you've got to clear the water
and i mean it is kind of reasonable
because these rockets the way they are
now they are pretty dangerous
like a lot of them do fail
[Music]
but um aircraft are different just
because they have wings
you can completely lose all your
propulsion and you can generally still
glide back you know it's not into the
mission so
with this first space plane you guys are
building how much
will you take to space and then and then
what's kind of the goal
as you make bigger and bigger space
planes yeah so
um the mark ii aurora will be able to
take four kilograms on a suborbital
flight
the mach 3 should be more like a
business jet size
that'll be able to get about 50 to 100
kilograms into orbit
it ascends just like a really high
powered aircraft
by the time it gets to the edge of the
atmosphere it's flying pretty much like
a rocket
once it gets to about 100 kilometers
altitude it'll release
a second stage just like a regular
rocket that second stage is going to fly
off into orbit and deliver a satellite
and it can actually turn around and
glide back to the launch site and land
just like an aircraft
in sci-fi we read about the idea of a
space plane all the time but yeah
why why hasn't somebody built one of
these so far and
why are you guys why do you guys think
you could actually do this
they actually did try to
the air force in particular started on
space planes
the x-15 roars free on a tongue of flame
that power is enough to shoot nearly 59
miles into space it eventually all fell
over because of
we just had to go beat the russians to
space you know and the easiest way to do
that was rockets
we revisited that with the space shuttle
yep that's a huge space plane that thing
is massive
but actually it lost every element that
would have made it an
aircraft in every other way it was a
rocket
it's just that it had wings for landing
there were then a whole bunch of other
programs but in the end they all fell
over because the government
no longer wanted to back them but the
reason
you can do a space plane project now is
because of the small satellite market
you know we don't have to build
something capable of taking 20 tons of
orbit
how 20 kilograms would be fine and then
the
just the amount of venture capital going
into space now
has gone up hugely and so there is
actually commercial appetite for this
stuff
and it's this kind of confluence of
things that makes
space planes actually make sense now i
think the big inflection point for us
is being able to show that yeah we have
properly reusable
space launch technology we can go fly a
plane
that is a plane in every single wave but
it has the performance of a rocket
if we can do that basically on fuel
costs plus a little bit of engineering
time
that's the game changer because you're
gonna cut your total flight cost
by 96 percent
the price you guys are talking about for
a launch i mean say
you've taken it from millions of dollars
to thousands of dollars to get something
into space
it sort of like opens up this new world
to run all these experiments
that people have been clamoring to do
we found that molecules do weird things
when there's
no gravity we found that the plants grow
in strange ways dna
behaves differently and materials
can be made to do different things
absolutely and that's
why we're working on such a far-out
technology
in-space manufacturing is going to be
the next big thing you know
multi-trillion dollar industries could
spawn out of this
we need space planes or we need proper
frictionless
access to space to actually make this
happen we want to be able to
make space more accessible i mean that's
kind of our whole ethos you know space
is kind of
for everyone and i saw i think i saw
that you guys
did this kind of cool thing where you
you put out as almost like a contest
that people could do the design
on the outside of the of the space plane
was that just for
students how did how did that work no it
was open to everyone
we had students like you know we had 10
year old kids put in designs um
as well as design studios and all kinds
of people from all over the world
space is something the whole world
should be participating in
and so um why not open that up to
everyone else
and you had a contest on the payload too
right yeah yeah so the prize was
actually um
that if you designed the winning paint
job it would fly a payload for you but
funnily enough the company that won it
didn't have too much interest in flying
a payload so we actually found another
contestant that had the best payload
centaurus school in colorado and they
want to
measure pollutants in the high
atmosphere
were you like a space geek growing up
and you knew you always wanted just
like what were you into as a kid no like
i wasn't really a space geek
i actually went to university thinking
that i was going to get into sustainable
technology wind turbines and whatever
but i actually got to the university and
realized that there's not much practical
stuff you can do with them it's not
particularly hands-on
but there was this really cool
university group building rockets
i could get stuck in there and actually
start building stuff and putting solid
rocket motors together
it was epic experience yeah
and one thing i wanted to talk about too
is is you guys
you want to make basically simpler
cheaper thrusters for
for satellites yeah so scalable uh high
performance
um non-toxic chemical propulsion for
cubesats and small satellites
we can mass-produce these they're
relatively simple they're relatively
easy to put together
they click onto their satellite and they
can give mobility to their constellation
that's a mature product now you can go
online and buy it
we actually have it in our webshop you
can actually add to carton
buy a rocket motor with your credit card
if you want so you guys have a couple
things going on you're doing the
business
around around the thrusters
and then the biggest milestone is the
space plane to start
running some of these flight tests as
soon as you can yeah exactly
if we're successful that'll then be the
first vehicle to ever be able to fly to
space twice in a day
we think that's kind of the
game-changing moment that's the like
okay you know we've actually got
properly reusable space systems
you